danielves se quedará en la cárcel la
audiencia de vaso lona lo ha decidido
Este martes tras haber escuchado a ambas
partes la semana pasada Al final
desestima este recurso presentado por
los abogados del futbolista brasileño y
en un auto detallado de 13 páginas basa
en su decisión en dos principales
argumentos uno pues que existen indicios
de criminalidad contra Dani Alves que
recuerdan pues cambio hasta tres veces
de versión y dicen que estos indicios no
sólo parten de la declaración de la
denunciante sino que también hay
testigos y pruebas de ADN segundo
argumento el riesgo de fuga pese a la
solicitud del abogado de Dani Alves de
ponerle en libertad a cambio de paga una
fianza de entregar el pasaporte incluso
de llevar una pulsera telemática seguían
medidas insuficientes
en la magistrada ponente que añade que
además el riesgo de fuga hoy es mayor ya
que el señor Gálvez conoce todos estos
indicios que pesan sobre él esta
decisión ya no se puede recurrir la
investigación está a punto de estar
finalizada y daña Alves se quedará en la
cárcel a la espiga de su juicio por
agresión sexual por el que arriesga
entre 4 y 12 años de cárcel